hello guys welcome to the insane Indiana
game show various we're going to talk
today about end games where one side has
the advantage of pair of Bishops and the
other one doesn't have the pair of
Bishops so and we'll try to understand
why pair of Bishops such a great sort of
such an important is not great but such
an important aspect of positional
advantage that can be used in chat
especially in the endgame and before any
of that happens
I would try to demonstrate in two
puzzles that are kind of I mean first
one is pretty relatively easy but the
second one is actually very hard so I'm
not gonna ask to ask you guys to solve
any of those puzzles because we don't
have time unfortunately for all that the
automatic content that I have today
especially the later and I want to show
to Brean and games played by Magnus
Carlsen and in Croatia the Grantchester
in Zagreb the he played against the
maxima allograph and dingle run and
because of that I just want to show the
Shabbos puzzles which basically they are
very very illustrative and instructive
as well so yeah let's just get started
he's a Bushman there yeah so this is the
first position and as you guys can see
basically why these two is like endgame
study sort of so here the in the first
one what what what is wise to move and
basically the white has to stop the pond
so neither free is the most logical move
Bishop Jeffrey also could be logical but
nineties doesn't do anything on h2 and
usually is good to bring the 19 so right
a3 is a good move I guess you know the
chart
all right and I have free and right now
there are basically two moves a block
has Bishop d2 Bishop g3 a king c2 for
instance
and now very nice idea here for for
white Bishop c8 King d1 as an intern
trying to play a one finally but no
Bishop g4 and even is impossible okay if
even one happens the night x1 move check
and white wins so it's the little trick
that white has kind of like shows the
track of pair of bishops and another the
main line goes King III night II one
logical just to stop the palm block it
again black has two options let's say if
King F to 93 King F one Bishop III
stopping the pawn because he won was
obviously a big threat therefore be free
stops it should be to reuse the file
right now very nice move Bishop h4 and
the idea behind this move is that if he
won Queen night X t1 visual takes one
and just King a4 for instance and
basically there is discovered track and
King has to go somewhere
for instance Kim G 2 and visual text you
want just with the bishop there is
nothing a white black can do it what I
just wins so it just shows how strong
garbage the bishops are and shows their
mobility in end games especially when
they're like how they can control
basically the entire board rather than
just small fragment as the Knights
usually do
and and finally see that the main line
King d2 bishop jeffrey defending the
knight King d1 King do you wanna be sure
before is the same basically lying
Bishop before we can start with the
Bishop age four and right now there is a
problem if Bishop g5 unfortunately that
there is not a free track and if King d1
with the fork and if King D 1 then white
the winds were in very nice wave of King
c4 which up the tube which should be
five Bishop takes II one Bishop a4 and
if King c1 then simply Bishop takes a
one and what wins and if King took the
reduce of g5 made so it all I mean of
course it's just study but and it's kind
of like compost position sort of made up
but anyway it just shows how strong the
bishops can be and it just shows what it
was their potential and in such studies
with a very limited material it's very
nice to see how the world's bishops can
really operate the same sort of thing
applies in in a real game and we'll see
sort of similar ideas maybe not making
ideas but Bishop regular relating to
bishops mobility in the endgame in the
game of car Magnus Carlsen versus
Dingley run from Croatia it was nineteen
and so this is the first position the
the second position I wanted to talk
about is not this game it's this one is
this position and here this place is
also very very difficult to solve
especially it's very very abstract but
anyway never never does
I was impressed by the solution and I
just want to quickly show how how it
goes because I found it like just
stunning so the I found institution just
solution just stunning and because I
mean seemingly white is just about to
lose the game just exchanged on was
night on mission I don't chip shop on
each seven-hour misplaced is very likely
sort of that they will be under attack
at some point design be shown the twisty
under attack so it seems like very tough
position for white but Bishop h6 is the
first move King f7 running away from the
checking e5 difficult oook self comes
better moved to be honest if let's say
f3 then would be faced probably by now
g3 and sort of it's sort of getting a
puzzle if here came to 596 for instance
I think if I probably better move but
still it's kind of like doesn't feel
right sort of so if King g5 sort of like
seems like correct move 97 track in d5
Knight b6 kinky 5 of course white is
happy with a draw Knight x f2 9 f6 if
what can try to consolidate the pieces
of course blue plate is a fret then we
had draw but the thing is white had
black has lots of tricks here let's say
rook c5 then King D for a rook c6 for
instance Bishop g5 of course who types
of sixes will be just the draw right now
when I teach free we should g8 King G 6
Bishop h4 and to be honest I've had for
hard time here to figure out what would
black do next because the thing is that
in here if Bishop h4 immediately didn't
would be Bishop c4 that's why we to
start off Bishop g8 and if Bishop g8
basically covers the C 4 square and
no Roxy for there for another 90 for the
394 and probably white can halt it's
still some game but there is no way the
white blocking with some piece
immediately not I can see at least there
are four better tries rooks is 6 because
hitting on this fur on the six Frank
both pieces Bishop g8 King g6 and right
now it appears that black the white
cannot defend the night or the bishop
and but as theme suggests we should
preserve the bishop not tonight
therefore Bishop he frees the best move
Bishop to release of six Bishop h7 and
for instance King g7 autores line of
King Gaston will get there later King
g7m Bishop d4 and this is very beautiful
position my opinion because right now
it's impossible to make progress even
though white is on the whole route down
it's impossible to for black to win it
and this position I just find like
really really impressive
for instance if Roux cake for instance
rook c6
just Bishop a5 now the name of twist
King so that has to do something about
it if be 91 just bishop before hitting
the rock again a rook has to retreat on
summer and see Frank because otherwise
nanomachines will be lost
look f6 for instance Bishop c2 hitting
the the night and night of two Spurs to
be the best move and let me shove a five
back and it's very very hard for for
black to make progress here possibly is
just dead draw here
but anyway such idea is very very
impressive and it only shows again how
powerful bishops are especially in the
center of the board when they control
basically all the squares let's say this
is shown rook a free Bishop before the
similar thing again there is no way that
if Brooke has to basically come back to
f6 and Bishop eight seven back for us
and just draw also Bishop a5 is possible
and if here Bishop which would be under
sorry rook h6 for instance
we shall be five also if the track
follows then kinky fork for instance
just dramatically because King aged
seven takes takes there is no way back
and windows also Brooke h6 King Bishop
a5 NIDA into best line best try for
black to win this is 9h one according to
what I tracked Bishop e6 night eight
which is very hard to play first first
two star would be 75 97 and right now
Bishop takes h1 rook takes a trunking d6
and we are taking the knight back and
the draw I found this study especially
disposition of the bishop d4 very very
instructive and it again shows how
strong bishops are at the endgame
let's quickly look at King of 7 line
here after Bishop is our King f7 because
it's
it's also possible however if we look at
it it's basically kind of like mirror
image of the previous line bishop on h7
therefore what what happens is the best
line sort of mirror moves of what was
happening earlier Bishop rook f8 Bishop
e6 98 earlier what I was going to h1 if
I'm mistaken oh no no yeah that's not
just one idea but yeah the same thing
but right now we are taking the other
night so Bishop b4 93 and we take this
guy and King a 4 is basically mirror
image of the previous line so yeah that
that's it this is the solution they want
to show and that shows how strong
bishops are in the end games they're
saying that having that in mind let's
look what did Magnus Carlsen
in his recent games from 2019 from
Grantchester in Zagreb Croatia
let's open first game they won't talk
about is actually the last game of the
tournament but nevertheless it was
I think I think it's it was a little bit
easier than against think the restaurant
start with this one
it was Magnus versus McIntosh Maxine
vascular graft and the for tonight of
6046
it was a group felt very popular lines
before night XD freebie cc5 Bishop III
queen 85 Queen d2 96 Robbie one city is
default takes takes and we got to the
typical grünfeld and game night xa5 we
should be free we should be for short
castle in this position maxi photograph
made a big mistake from strategic point
of view and in my opinion after this
mistake is very very hard for black to
kind of sort of come back and you know
to equalize because Maxine played Bishop
takes a free and this move sort of just
gives away the power of Bishops
voluntarily and within getting nothing
in return
yes the structure could someone may
claim that structure right now is besom
basically messed up for white but this
structure doesn't really matter very
often actually white can play a four and
a pond and if five and then this pawn on
f4 and stabilizes the center in pawn
wild pond enough to stabilize Bishop
only three so actually it's white favor
therefore this Bishop takes a free move
was very very bad and taking into a
kicking kind of like a moment because I
also play ground fault with black myself
posture with white I just want to
discuss briefly what was supposed to be
played and what could have been the
alternative and in my opinion but linear
Dominguez play 2015 v6 move was correct
and here I think white has the black has
decent chances to eat pies
and the main difference is that in very
many lines if white goes Bishop a6 one
of the ideas here for black is to play
Bishop c8 back and basically this night
on this Bishop on Essex doesn't stand
there as we'll see in the game what
happened is visualize it was extremely
annoying
and here [ __ ] after Bishop takes Bishop
c8 black can simply equalize so yeah let
me just cut this opening is called
ground fault
it's one of the most popular openings
and Maxine vasila graph
who plays runaway candidates is the one
of the major specialist of this opening
in the world
so b6 B C's was the best move and for
instance there are several options here
for widen for black but in general white
black tries to maintain the price
detention and not to take only free
unless really needed for instance rook
FC wand and posit there are
possibilities to play rook
88 or f d8 in the game of dominguez
verse book FD 8d v e6 is the game how it
went
possibly there were some improvements
but for instance the game went like this
and as you can see position is pretty
much on completely unbalanced anything
can happen on d6 is right now object of
an attack but there but there are some a
95 ideas I came back one can also play
rook c7 maybe at some point maybe don't
know because we taken booth HD free but
also taking on c8 deflecting the attack
on d6 it's some game you know it's some
game and the I wouldn't say that white
is better here possibly there were some
mistakes done there was a grand back for
the game went but also there's no rock
88 d v e6 and this leads to also very
very sharp play for inception g5 f6
Bishop d2 it takes d5 and now it's this
impossibility
apart from be take say if I which is
probably fine it's possibility of
tagging e4 and this also is leads to
some crazy and games like this
actually black is this black quest pair
of pair of Bishops also a pawn actually
two pawns for the exchange and I don't
think black has any trouble embark is in
trouble here therefore saying that let's
see what happened in the game and why
this visual take the free move was so
bad and this is essentially the reason
why Maxime lost this game map in because
after take stagger Styles my free tags
on f3 d6 typical move stop in d5 Magnus
hydrograph d1 preparing at some point to
play d5 look at the 8 typical movement
having good so far we shall be 1 and
right now it's sort of hard to make a
move for black because 35 is coming at
some point maybe maybe also has emerged
earlier at 45 and bringing G talking a
freaking before or just bring the King
to a free lesson and play d5 at some
point then prepare f5 some pawn
breakthroughs
it's not so pleasant but let's let's
think why yes perturbation is one thing
but there is other factor that may
simply contributes to the fact that it's
not so pleasant for the indisposition
the disposition is also Pleasant for
black to play and the reason for that is
1985 in all the lines here designed on a
file it's basically misplaced and it's
not and on top of that it's very hard to
bring this back night back to the game
yes poor night on 85 it's very hard to
bring it back because if the Night Moves
for instance now there could be move
like 85 and this point basically the
Hoos have to go back otherwise point
before Besson will be lost in case of
let's say Luke 88 which was the most
natural move it drops the pawn actually
because d5 Edie Edie
and right now d6 is a big threat so
let's see if b6 or I mean first of all a
sixth for instance we should be six and
bishops again dominate designer if I so
bad is just being lost or the exchange
and if b6 is possible to play also d6
it's also possible to play Bishop h6 is
also possible to play we should be five
but I really like these six to be honest
and it's hard to stop this pawn from
advancing forward because if Brooke g7
there is we should be 5 for instance 96
is a master Brook Lucas e1 seems like by
what is just winning so yeah it seems
like and if black has to get the just
you know play Bishop afraid and at least
there is Bishop takes a7
possibly Bishop Jafar as I was checking
is also possible but Bishop takes a7
looks simply more than enough just
getting the free pawn and seems like
that just came over nearly at at their
level of I mean their level by their
level I mean carcinogen rush allograph
because you know pawn up pair of bishops
intact should be more than enough in
classical game anyway so I was and
actually it's hard to come with the move
because I was trying to figure out what
black can do in action not so easy
because for instance
Bishop f6 possibly was the best move but
it doesn't really solve anything
like for instance what can wife has many
moves sf4 possible preparing e5 as I
said earlier Ruby c1 is possible of idea
of bringing the rook to c7 he has allows
Isis but again d5 and takes takes time
before bring knight comes back comes to
the game but the sixth VII of next 57
seems like very very unpleasant to face
and I couldn't equalize here with black
either but possibly it was the better
chance because at least here this night
is coming back to the game so tactically
in some lines maybe black we got lucky
but with this night on a5 in like it was
like it's here if he's not coming back
to the game it's impossible to do
anything actually simply because it's
not even tactically because it's night
it's just not in the game and will never
be in the game so my maximum try to
solve the problem of this night by
playing move b6 which is very very
questionable I would say simply I
understand he wants play knight c6 and
bring this knight of the game and that
proverb prevents this
I mean manualized the pawn mission will
not be hanging so sort of his holy
fascist structure but right now Magnus
played very strong with Bishop h6 and
this move controls takes under control
as c8 Square and after this move this
Knight is again not coming back to the
game because knight c6 would be met by
Bishop d7 it's very instructive and I
will quickly drop back to what I said
earlier why it was bad to take on f6 a
free in this life he played b6
for instance in case of Bishop a6 well
we will be sure to see a trading post
bishops
right now without this Bishop it's
completely busted because right now in
this position this Bishop is just white
very light square bishop is not there
and why don't we boys bishop on e6 has
no rival
and basically dominating the
design on a five and COSO controlling
the CA square right now Ruby c1 Roxy
seven is the sad reality that at some
point black will have to face and solve
this how the game ended to be honest so
but let's see what - what happened that
later Ruby six logical trying to play
rook 88 and hit on d4 and trying to cut
some color play and the right now I
think Magnus played a little bit in in
accra a little bit inaccurate move BC
one however this move looks makes
perfect sense as well and I wouldn't say
the mistake is this may be a little bit
inaccurate because i from what I
analyzed with our white had to bear
alternatives but this move also doesn't
spell any and doesn't spoil anything
does ruin any advantage maybe it just
makes car sometimes Carson starts a
little bit harder than it should be
normally but it doesn't respond
advantage but the easiest way to
basically reactors would be just routed
to group the a true t1 and basically
just preparing everything because the
thing is that ninety six is not really a
threat because then would be lets say
ninety six then just a 5 and this nine
never has a good square because the
fructify be should be seven still pin on
here and if Bishop rook d7 then we
should be five and pin here and yes what
what black can go for this but let's say
rook historic c1 is a remark CL Roxy -
on this pin right now
white just means a piece therefore that
isn't still not an option and having
said that wide you can just follow up
with a 45 prepare maybe d5 at some point
also is possible to prepare for the if I
also is possible to play d5 instead of
this depends what white likes basically
but the thing is that Knight isn't still
not coming to the game and it's very
very hard
for black it was the simplest other
possible was also very nice if I've Roxy
six Roxy one-eyed right now only move
basically is one of the only few only
moves Ruby eight because what has to
black history actor up text 6/9
exhibition b7 for instance if a bishop
of eight takes takes we should be some
who just wins and if Ruby eight for
instance we should be five rook c8
a for again this night just never comes
back it's very unlikely we'll come back
why to follow was up follows up with d5
it is white actually who was better
chance of controlling the C file and
it's very hard position for black to
play also it's possible to simply
improve the position of White King King
G talking a free bring it bring it there
may be at some point I go CID five start
using making use of majority on the
center and King side because on the
Queen side while blacks pawns are not
going anywhere because they're again
dominated by the light square bishop and
yeah it's just much better for white and
the rock PC one also is good but it's
not as good as the twelve turns with
suggest possibly even more alternatives
but this I don't really think the rupees
one was the best move
because roopd eight Bishop g5 hitting
the rock f6 Bishop e3 and right now I
think Maxime had to simply had to
activate his night it was his last
chance basically to activate this night
and if he doesn't do it simply he'll be
just lost in like matter of few moves
basically and
this is what happened first of all let's
see what he should not do for him to
play a 5 because Bishop g5 just wins and
considering that logical move because f5
sort of like his typical idea opening
this bishop and the attacking on d4 but
if a 5 Bishop g5 it's unpleasant to face
because then rook from d8 has to move
somewhere and then there is no really an
attack for on d4 and this rook on
distance will be again let's say if rook
e8 for instance this possibility to play
e5 as possible to play Bishop b5 as well
also d5 in five uh normally I feel like
so much but let's say d5 looks very good
and I'm sorry the e5 looks very good and
then Roxy sever something like this also
Bishop b5 looks good Brooke c7 looks
good even stacking a pawn on d4 is more
than enough for sure lose just winning
or like a least huge advantage let's
whack hit play h6 which is logical
because he prevents Bishop g5 which he
realizes was so dangerous but it has
this drawback that it creates just one
idea one threat of a5 but doesn't really
create any other ideas that what black
can do anything else and the leaves
white sort of like with the huge choice
but white can do and
what can basically win nearly on the
spot here but the best defense was basic
96 basically we'll design a five white
black cannot do anything if the sight
comes back to the game at least maybe
tactically in some lines as possible to
survive that's why the best chance was
to play just simply 96 and this is also
shows was that usually if you have bad
position in endgame when your openers
pair of Bishops try to activate all your
pieces as much as you can and here even
96 maybe it doesn't work we don't know
this was during the game but is it
anyway the best chance they would use
you can try in order to confuse or marry
the waters or try to confuse her
opponent tactically there this is the
only chance basically if you play moves
like h6 you don't gonna make any of that
because 9 is the only five and two
always pieces are perfectly placed
nothing tactically will ever work for
black here so 96 was the only transfer
let's see what happens d5 he takes d5
and right now White has two options both
look decent I'm not sure not sure which
one strong a probably rook takes d5 is a
little bit stronger trading one pair of
rooks let's say rotates defied it takes
d5 97 and for instance I looked at
Bishop before which is also again very
hard enough to play the most let's say
natural move rook c7 that's actually
thing because I didn't read check that
but I think that Knight takes d5 would
be unpleasant after Bishop c4 but on the
other hand I don't see a follow up after
King f8 so here it is already quite okay
for black because neither on if white
don't take on Bishop and you should take
defiled and pawn and white black will
take on if free and this would be pretty
much draw ish and still white is better
but will be hard to win but it's not an
efficient ad to xt5
the new rook takes d5 obtains a 7 also
it's very low material and suddenly
white doesn't have any
or the pair of bishop invented it should
be fairly close to the roster b5 for
instance so it's not so easy anymore and
[ __ ] but this uh before would be very
nice move that the cars would have to
find here because ideas to play d6
simply and yet another idea is that this
pollen defies poisoned what i cannot
retake it because rotate twenty Bishop
c4 pin and after night xd5 in the other
pin with rook d1 and Bishop c4 follows
there is no defense from that and just
came over the side g5 Bishop G free
surface game over there is no no defense
from Bishop c4 and so on
I've ever right now maybe there is a
five but still like if I could but even
a four or just even fh 4 or something
beef basically this Bishop c4 still
remains such a strong threat such a big
threat that there is there can be any
salvation here for for black I really
like it for to be honest because after
this we can even take a [ __ ] for hit
the rock again and then Bishop c4 for
instance so say having said that Bishop
a4 we were her move to find and
tactically you know if I it doesn't find
it certainly it can get tricky because
point if I was hanging so this is the
best the way to play it let's say first
King of eight I thought Bishop c4 just
simply just much better for white
because nine take it if I still not
possible cause of roopd one but you know
neither this is only seven not only five
right now and it's possible to play
Knight c8 maybe 96 or 95 96 maybe 95
Bishop h6
you know it's some game it's still not
clear whether white can
really win this with the best defense
the black can I can do definitely was
much better but it's not so easy to win
this I'm a peon
but h6 was a terrible move
unfortunately for Maxine simply because
right now it gives essential Tempe to
forwards sort of activity and Magnus
didn't take his chance right now which I
was little surprised to see because what
can be because if I right now B should
be fire and I thought we should be five
basically he stops the idea of ninety
six which we earlier said it was the
best defense for black and it's
perfectly logical and generally very
good move but the thing is and also does
is for advantage but the thing is is
white cat he had Martinez had something
much stronger here and what can be the
most logical here move in my opinion for
white is just Roxy 767 entering the
seventh ranked everything is just still
dominated and right now we just collect
upon an i7 and it doesn't seem like
there is enough you know anything about
black can do let's see fruit deserves or
erupted seven for instance rocks you
want
prefer think we should be 5 for instance
next and the entering seventh ranked
either way it was just winging and if 96
bring the night back the five for
instance takes takes takes takes night
before Bishop c4 Knight takes d5 rook
takes a seven and next we should tasty 5
for instance false friend I mean X is
possibly should XD 5 also if there is a
friend of rook a8 which is very nice
tactical idea but there also we should
take b6 so bothered save black can play
King h7 for instance at least they're
abusing takes d5 rook takes d5 we should
be six and what is just pawn pawn up
this pawn just fall goes forward and
there is no way of stopping it just pawn
up simply winning position without group
without bishops would be easier for
black to defend it possibly would be
even just that draw but with bishops on
the board and rooks in there it's in
basically just winning for white
therefore c7 I was really surprised
amongst team play because seems like so
natural but he played we should be 5
which is also very good and right now
Magnus
I'm sorry Maxine had really nice
defensive resource that was also again
very very hard to figure out especially
over the board because Bishop b5 - fret
instructor 7 renews the fret I mean
still has this Fred and there is no root
d7 possible maybe he didn't like
something in there but Bishop a focus is
on drawback that right now there is very
strong move g5 and this is very computer
which sort of moves I can pull I did a
play like that simply because no one
would ever play here with g5 unless you
see a clear reason to to play this move
and then first first of all why why why
g5
let's see what happens after f5 because
it seems like the most natural move the
white black can do and
there was entire point of playing age
six and this is what Maxime played so
after a five this is sort of like
returning the favor we should be five
inaccuracy - played d5 and this just
came over and the the main difference is
that after it takes d5 Bishop a4 follows
and white kicks the rope from d6 let's
say rook is six then Bishop c7 kicks
through from d8 then pull it takes d5 d6
d7 d8 Queen game over so saying that the
difference is that after it takes d5
White has Bishop a4 square for the
bishop it's very subtle it's very deep
but that's how just nowadays works
therefore he played g5 maxing play here
g5 but it's already too late because
right now there is another path on the
route for the bishop - basically the
rook from d6 and this is the palace
would exactly man who's played Bishop d2
an official custom before hitting the
rogue on g6 and this simply game over
this is just winning for white and there
is nothing black can do therefore let's
see what would happen after g5 because
right now in all those lines there is
never Bishop before possible f5 remains
a threat and after d5 he takes d5 there
is no it there is no Bishop f4 Bishop d2
makes no sense because it detects if or
simply wins here Bishop d2 makes no
sense because a rook takes d4 and
suddenly it's not easy to find what to
do next and let's say the most natural
move would be here okay seven button f5
and this is exactly what maximum on it
I'm sure right now next move possibly is
a four bit of days or Bishop takes d4
it's very unclear
therefore I think the in general the
were to what should do is to play d5
nevertheless he takes d5 and now rock c7
basically to go for activity still
banking on this night on if I five is
not coming to the game and if it's not
coming to the game while I it will
retain majority of the advantage let's
see if detects before I think rotates
the signal strong takes and context
before important lessons nevertheless
false which to understand is very bad
and I think what is still what still has
big advantage if it is not winning
already
therefore d4 is maybe better chance
button Bishop d2 a6 very important move
a6 simply because after this and this
night is not there anymore on i-5 but
rugby one gives two white big advantage
and it possibly was the best what
maximum could have gotten out of the out
of all of this but anyway if Magnus have
found that would be just you know bear
for wide but yeah it was the best
defense g5 which is very very so very
very hard to figure out over the board
especially when you h6 with the clear
fixed idea of him of playing f5 next
move so
yeah that's why after we should be 5g if
I was the best defense but f5 was which
is the most natural it is what Maxime
played d5 now g5 is comes a little bit
too late if he started with g5 was
better move order basically and now
Bishop d2 just games just came over and
let's see what happens takes only four
texts only for a six giving the pawn but
trying in any way to create some
tactical issues for white because if
takes then takes a sudden could be not
so clear but we push by far is simply
much stronger because after takes on the
fibrous Bishop before and to black rook
has to go away from g6 rookie six rook
takes d5 and right now maybe the best
defense work group b8 and after which
what has a big choice but probably the
simplest will just takes takes rook c4
and having the control of their over the
light squares here both two pawns
basically are like a white one pawn pawn
on e5 anyway dropping soon most likely
and the free versus stone a king side
and the very strong control over the
light squares and with next we should be
free for instance also rope rooks
controlling the send the central files
coming to d7 working very safe White's
King it seems like just what is just
winning here maybe was the best chance
to try to hold it but would on trying to
hope to basically tried all the routes
and escape some bishop and game
different of a scholarship and game but
it can I don't think that's possible not
to be honest so rook takes d5 it takes
d5 happen in the game and there is just
very straightforward because again ID
from a5 doesn't come to the game on the
d5 point just marches forward there is
no way of stopping it and just it's just
game over rookie for lets you out and it
will be for Roxy it can give
a free Bishop b5 Bishop piayed King g7
d6 pawn just goes on goes on forward
there is no way of stopping it now b7
finally then I've moved but to b7 which
is not a great square which shall be 7
ths coming again and we should be for
Ruby for Roxy 6 we should be 47 and this
is where maxim resigned because after
Luke take C 7 the simpler route XP 7 and
the 8 there is no waste of stopping the
18s a rupee 1 in G to Bishop f6 d8 Queen
and there is discover check so let's
simply game over
and after Roxy seven yeah wait here Roxy
seven this is were maxim resigned so
yeah great nice technique by Magnus
despite some inaccuracies and some very
often hidden defensive resources for
Maxim over I was brilliant endgame and
just shows how strong bishops are and
what kind of what bad night in such
positions can basically mean for the
defensive side if there is bad night
position which is collapsing or I'd be
about to be collapsing and this is what
happen in the game all right
and let's see finally the last game that
I want to talk about and this was
equally is not disposition equal
instructive as the previous game here I
will skip the opening because there was
it was very sharp and let's just focus
on the endgame and I want to start
discussing from this position rook e8
last move was basically rook e8
and here position is around equal but
the question is what to do next with
white because why is to move and it's
not easy to I know suggest what to do
next because what if I was hanging and
why didn't do something about it and
basically there are two main kind of
like candidate moves that I would
consider for white here either
Queen c6 or queen b7 but if you try to
treat Queens and maybe don't trade drugs
or maybe not trade routes depends what
white black does and basically going to
try to make draw here because definitely
what is no better here and because of
the pair of bishops some pressure on f2
also Bishop of two right now is a big
big threat there for white needs to do
something here very very drastic not to
lose the game on the spot it's there two
moves basic with six queen or king b7
and both of them look equally appealing
at the first sight but if you look at it
a little bit deeper
it seems become it becomes clear that
one of them is very bad and one of them
leads to is okay and this to let's say
equal position so let's see
let's see I mean the chart
I can't understand anyway queasy 6 it
was one more that I want to discuss and
second moves Quinby Quimby 7 and the
thing is here which one's better because
if you have two choices too many choices
maybe there are other moves but mostly
focus on here you have to make the
decision you are in the game so let's
see what happens after Queen c6 takes
takes Bishop h5 ok ok let's let's stop
here take stakes and let's evaluate the
position if we evaluate this push at
this point it seems like why this fine
simply because this night put some
pressure on before put some pressure on
the 87 on those bones it kind of like
takes some square from the rope some
maybe eight square takes from the rock
maybe seven square from the rock it it
does lots of functions on c6 and also
very well protected by this Bishop g2
maybe why we want to play a five a six
at some point and try to fix this pawn
on g7 seems like it's okay
this position for four for white and
let's look at the alternative Queen d7
takes takes bishop f8 and
what about this night right now is this
not good or bad
in my opinion it's not great simply
because it doesn't really do anything in
there yes it maybe controls the eighths
perform the rook sometimes sometimes not
to ensure when it would even matter but
basically it has no future because this
Bishop from f8 covers nine votes to 12
two squares d6 and c5 it seems like this
bill tonight doesn't go anywhere from
there it doesn't attack any of those
pawns they were supposedly object on an
attack earlier and it's hard to make
next move for white basically after to
move calculation is really easy to
figure out why one of the moves is
better than the other because at first
sight it seems like poverty Quilly good
because both trade Queens and please to
similar structure same structure same
everything but the mobility of pieces
suddenly tells us different story and
with leather c6 is just positioning y
solutions fine while it would then be 7
it's bad
someone told me once the die on b7
basically be 7g 7g 2p to think it was me
- [ __ ] so pass regards to me how
basically one of those squares Knight is
the booster bore square for the knight
therefore sank having said that this was
a mistake we miss a most mistake in in
this therefore Queen c6 was the best
move here after text text wish of h5 and
Roxy 1 suddenly nice under bishop is
under attack
a knight on statistics is very well
placed hits both pawns
if Bishop moves to a FF let's say Knight
excess already wins the pawn and yes
what Bacchus - [ __ ] rookie - and there
is enough conversation for sure but and
but white is clearly clearly not worse
for instance b3 bishop of stone
understand flat is 96
Ruby - if we shall be free already 94
wins have a look how this nylon system
is active already we can take pawn
because 94 is very very strong and just
seems like it weighs or nearly wins for
white definitely what is not in any
trouble here if ruby - there are
possible to pay just 95 willing to make
just a draw because we should text be
free women by takes tags and different
color bishops just draw any be Ruby -
butter zoom of a5 which is very sort of
aggressive and least 2/4 drop basically
pie Luke takes b3 a 6
who gave 3 a 7 be free and just Ruby one
right now the next heavy the bishop on
g2 supporting this pawn Knight has to
just jump somewhere attack on be free
and will be to ACP trade-off pawn on a 7
for the poem be free and just dead draw
so
yeah there will be they'll be it
basically for for the squeezy six move
why he was so why it was much better and
the main difference I will repeat that
lies in the activity of the night and
having flashback to the previous game by
versus Maxim again this night only five
in the previous game was very very bad
and right now it's similar idea that
after Quint xb7 this night on b7 will be
very very bad and this will be source of
the problems for for the defending side
meaning for white here so let's see
let's see what happens also in the roof
there was Bishop b6 which was also very
possible and possibly was maybe level
more accurate but let's not go into
details about that because there is not
much much of a difference between those
two moves let's say a5 Bishop d4 I
analyzed something and Vols lines are
pretty complicated I don't think it's
really important really important
because Bishop avail is much simpler
move that car somebody very practical
and I really really like his decision
let's say Bishop e5 and I know Kim G -
there is b3 move you know there is lots
of lots of move for instance if Kim G 2
is not good to take on b2 because ninety
six you know there there is some game
going on and basically be completely
different game let's just focus on what
Carson in his game we should have eight
I really like this one because it
restricts at night from coming to c5 or
c6 and right now Dingley run made a huge
mistake simply because he played Bishop
c6 and it seems like it's very natural
move but again in this such positions
in general when opponent has pair of
bishops and you're defending side you
need to focus on maximum improvement of
your pieces I mean it's obvious applies
almost everywhere but especially in such
an Cain's value graph we are defending
need to create the most practical active
problems for opponent actively and right
now the worst piece in the positions on
b7 it no doubt about it no
no wonder like me said doesn't do
anything has no future basically there
so it must be activated somehow and the
only way to activate was to play 98 and
the idea is to finally bring this knight
to c6 and try to make draw like that and
let's see what happens because for
instance Bishop if I have already a
mistake because 96 and again Knight
comes back to the game suddenly tricks
work for white some technical tricks
there for Bishop which fires possible
but till 96 give some tracks you know
some practical ideas it's not so clear
but anyway after night d8 rook takes did
it mapping is the best move and this
already gives possibility to maybe give
have some chance to escape in a
different color
I mean opposite color Bishop end games
roof d1 Bishop f1 Bishop to c5 and right
now this position I've in my opinion
why this still suffering while still
trying to make a draw here because yes
it seems like it's just a draw because
it's different color bishops why doesn't
have really big weaknesses here position
position is relatively solid but still
it is black with pushing here because of
the activity of the pieces and the fact
that white pawns are a little bit more
exploring than blacks pawns for instance
I last a little bit and I came to
conclusion that's pretty unpleasant for
white to play let's say Roxy to Bishop
e6 g4 and let's say rook a1 let's say be
free Ruby won already
suddenly there is no way to defend this
pawn on be free because Bishop is pinned
and pawn be free false if the bishop on
false seems like it is ringing for back
there for h3 has to be played or
something like this bouquet for Bishop
c4 trying to activate the bishop and
some position like this where black has
clearly some chances to win because just
a pawn up but on the other hand there
are different color bishops and
possibilities of making draw here
because the
like blockade men will be free Bishop b5
bishop a 4th and activating the rogue
there are there however if I will say
that if there were no rooks to be the
drop I will the roost on the board
suddenly there are many ideas because
sometimes what black may try to
sacrifice an exchange and activate the
king and of the hub of the past poem win
the game therefore I wouldn't say it's a
draw definitely what why this has to
still defend but the chances for to make
a draw are pretty pretty big but anyway
this was the best defense and Dingley
run didn't want to maybe suffer in such
an kV want to basically trade rooks and
this is what he was aiming for which is
also understandable but as we see as we
will see the endgame is not without
drugs is very very difficult for for
back it's very instructive visual 6mu
b73 Bishop c4 trading rocks and Trust
trust transforming the position to two
beautiful fur two bishops versus a
bishop and a knight rook takes seven
bishop takes seven King f2f five all
logical can give free Bishop g8 it's
nice little idea basically the bishop
there will not be in the way of blacks
King in many lies also we run into sort
of like unnecessary attack who from the
neither bishop or something just doesn't
stain them in the way of of blacks
pieces and King the free and this is the
most important position my I think from
the entire game after King d3 because
here as I checked both players had
around here like in a 30 or 40 minutes
so basically at lots of time we were
like 5 million 5 moves to the time
control and they had lots of time and
they could stay there time and figure
out things figure things out and the
here Carlsen played very natural move
and very logical move and move that
majority of the players would I think
play
but before I say this move let's try to
think what sort of an objective in this
type of endings the tale the main
objective for the attacking side is
basically to create a passport and they
will support of the bishops pair of
Bishops black can basically here try to
promote this pawn to the Queen at some
point or basically deflect White's
pieces to Wars positions and then create
a second pass pawn or something and then
we somehow like that but in general with
one weakness is impossible to win it and
therefore what I black needs to create
second weakness in order to have chances
of winning this this this game and right
now the first weakness is obviously pawn
on b2 is that this is the first weakness
no one no no wonder about that and it's
possibly it's possible to immediately
attack this this pawn will move like for
instance here Bishop f6
and this Bishop move Bishop f6 attack
spawning b2 and it's impossible to
defend it okay it's possible technically
a septic King C to F paliku but after be
free it gets really really because this
King has to go backwards and Bishop d4
comes in let's say King C to be free for
instance that's a king bee one Bishop d4
and it's very very unpleasant position
this bishop comes from behind here
bishop g1 King comes Pamba to is ver is
like a chronic weakness there is nothing
what can do about it
so therefore widens to again needs to
look for counter play for active counter
play F Bishop f6 attach the palma not be
to throw but also leaves d6 and c5
square for the knight available
therefore the best defense to play 96
and look for active counter play and
activate the night
Bishop takes be to night of 5 can give a
let's say also king of suppose possible
but that sticking of is maybe more
subtle by some reason I D free and right
now because white King is so close the
king queen side this poem if it doesn't
really matter the proof the threat of
Bishop d5 is suddenly also not easy to
to say what's next what the black should
do next and I don't think what this duck
is still definitely better but the way
to make the progress is not obvious at
all I would say even that if white
manages to trade bishops better build
wildlife square bishops and then somehow
block this beep on with the knight then
you know maybe try to surround this
before an a7 pause and try to win it
somehow
of course the very very long term and
probably will never happen but this is
ideal scenario for white that white is
hoping for let's see here and here it I
would say it could be possible in some
lines simply because it's not easy for
blacks I'd kind of like to win it there
for Bishop versus is premature here and
it's not black should basically try to
avoid attacking just one weakness but
try to create two weaknesses that black
can attack the same time sort of and
then by deflecting White's pieces from
one to another try to find a break for
them and this is what exactly Carson did
here and he pal here move g4 and right
now the up on top of pawn on b2 which is
a weakness which could be could have
been really attract right upon which to
becomes a chronic weakness as well and
this is very logical move a vertical
idea and so on because right now it's
impossible to move this pawn from eight
to anywhere and
looks like the most logical move that
what tells why black can do in this
position and I was when I was analyzing
this game I came to the brim - kind of
like conclusion that it wasn't actually
the best move that there was the same
idea but better execution of this idea
to create a second weakness and let's
see why let's see what happened in the
game or what could have happened in the
game because he played g4 and right now
dinkler sort of panicked I think or I
don't know what happened but he played
Knight a5 and it's understandable he
wants to activate this night but not
he's not activating it - really it's
activating it I mean it's a good idea in
general to activate this night but not
in the position where you have to
chronic weaknesses and suddenly you need
to make up your mind whether we are
going for passive defense or active
defense usually active defense desirable
but sometimes you need to make the
distinction whether which one is
necessary inappropriate for the position
and here after 95 what happened the game
is Bishop to c5 and this yes Knight is
more active right now because comes to
the game less than c4 any free but
blacks Bishop also is coming to the game
coming to g1 which is the bigger problem
rather than it was before and with a
bishop custodian simply is just game
over
therefore the best defense was to play a
5 here and after less and it's not so
easy because this night that what
Dingley run was supposed to realize here
and that night up from from b7 actually
covers both two squares were this bishop
ideally mainly okay hold on maybe not d6
square but mostly most very important at
C Phi square that covers this square
because otherwise if bishop comes to c5
and then visual comes to g1 later and if
Bishop d7 is covering it and doesn't
allow this Bishop actually to go
anywhere also keep on the freeze very
well place as it covers the Foursquare
and this bishop can go if this bishop
can get on this diagonal especially to
g1 blacks should win but if it doesn't
get there I don't really see how white
public can make a progress here because
King from the free cover is this square
not from Bissell cover c5 square also
can go from different free covers every
square it's not easy to find a break
from with with black and this was the
right moment basically to
realized the mission it could be a good
defensive idea which is very instructive
as well let's say Bishop f6 Bishop f6 96
already is is ok for black if for white
because again attacking d6 pawn I mean a
five point from d6 and there is no no
breakfast I did this this Knight h6 draw
sorry only kidding on g8 to get hit on
g4 our move h5 for instance a6 if Bishop
e6 and yeah like here there are there
are several options for black of course
is not draw but this is the best defense
for black trying to control all the
thinking in terms of pure prophylaxis
what black wants to do and basically
making sure that this doesn't happen and
right now black definitely wants to
drink this Bishop on this diagonal and
if rather with this sort of play this is
what black what white is doing basically
complete prophylaxis or of what to go to
black into next and yeah
and so yeah this was g4 move and it
suddenly is not so easy after g4 to win
it because after a 5 for instance this
h5 let's say some line like this days
this should be 5 F 7 still black tries
to come get environment Bishop before
but even after invasion of Bishop before
it's still not so clear because suddenly
White Nights jumps around gets activated
is not so easy and after Knight a5
Bishop to c5 just Bishop comes in
therefore but also here because there
was a defense of a5
it was much stronger to play here h5
which is such the same idea as g4
basically to create a postponed but the
idea is to play for instance after a 5
f4 and the idea is after this this
suddenly white black has entrance with
this King here which is very instructive
and this is different way of creating
second weakness same idea of trading
weakness but
from the Midway and in my opinion this
is very very unpleasant
I understand feel like this was already
postponed and the difference relative to
previous positions when White was taken
back on second poem b2 and giving the F
pawn right now most pawns are sorry are
misplaced and there would be objective
and attack for of whites of blacks King
like king of things will come some
checks King will try to invade somehow
and postpones are not very hard to
defend basically so this was the better
idea of h5 the same thing but their
execution and this will happen the game
because after 95 the good game is
basically over Bishop c5 Knight c4
bishop G 193 King Bishop e6 and Bishop
on g1 is just came over basically night
f1 is not sufficient either way because
King f6f for the second 7 King Bishop e5
and e6 and basically why blacks King is
inviting through c5 there's possibility
to die Bishop d5 Bishop b4 did not only
once completely tied up to pollen h2
basically their weaknesses on both both
sides born h2 from B to point only for
even it's impossible to defend it
basically just some random line kinky to
h5 just some random line of a few moves
here takes takes and King again invades
it's some random line one of the many
possible lines that could happen in this
game also here is possible to 25 and go
for this end game which is maybe a
little bit harder to win but still
should be winning somehow can be for
kindy too but it's no bit harder to
break through here but she still should
be winning because there are so many
weaknesses for for for white b3 and h2
and active King for black should be
winning let's see what happened the game
because it's possibly it's just already
just lost after takes takes King get to
h5 pwnage 2 is following of course we
are not trading bishops feeding on a4
here B should be free before me was
maybe was a little bit better but still
it's just seems like it just lost
doesn't change much a relative to the
game we shall be free
aah talking f2h for creating I mean
freeing the bishop having the passport
and right now the final picture are
going to show here is how Carson
improved his fine the last piece that he
need to improve a 500 before and right
now be sure basically King compass comes
with b2 c3 there is no way that what can
stop that and just complete domination
because I thought c4 cannot move because
then we should be free g2 and Queen and
is this what happens while just stands
in place King g1 King F one pushes pawns
but King comes to see free and just game
over
taking points and since were being
literally resigned it was very
instructive and game opinion and just
shows how strong pair of shots can be
but I also tried to point out what are
the best because sometimes you may end
up on being the worst side of the world
side of such an game so I also want try
to show what are the best approaches to
try to hold it somehow and hopefully
defend it eventually so hopefully it was
instructive and all was interesting and
I wish you to be on the positive side of
such end games obviously but if this
doesn't happen I hope that you will know
how to defend as well so that's all I
have for today thank you guys
you
[Music]